ccsd board president linda cavazos
addressing multiple issues within the
district this is dr jarrow was recently
fired from his position as
superintendent so since then we've
reported extensively on the allegations
of harassment a potential re-vote and
how the trustees will move forward kate
houston joining us now from the clark
county library with the details kate
yes trustee cavazo started with an
apology to the community saying that the
focus needs to be on improving student
achievement and accessibility for 45
minutes she addressed multiple problems
one of which at the top of everybody's
mind right now is a potential re-vote on
dr jarrah's termination she says in
order for that to happen there will need
to be a vote on whether to revote if it
moves forward that vote could take place
the very same evening trustee cavazos
was asked how they would move forward if
dara was reinstated
working with them is going to be i think
an individual question that all of us
are going to have to ask
and on this again it's going to have to
be
what do we need to do said again we're
not here talking about allegations where
we're talking about achievement
accessibility
cavazos also reacted to the document
from jarrah's attorney obtained
exclusively by channel 8 she says she
was puzzled and did not understand she
did address the allegations involving
her though saying she never indicated
the termination was for cause only for
convenience she also said the closed
session was called not
will be going available a retreat to
talk about team building and conflict
resolution she says that this was
actually planned a month ago reporting
live kate houston live local now